it's a new Iron Curtain being erected by
soldiers along the Serbian border the
fence will be four meters high and a
hundred and seventy five kilometers long
topped with barbed razor wire
Hungary's government sees building it as
a matter of national defence these are
the people they're trying to keep out
migrants most of whom have been on the
road for months now they're stuck
shortly before they reach their goal we
want to ask you something
well we're human we are not there
anymore so it is a big detachment I
don't want to ask you to cross we got
screwed I need to open the other body
does he feel everybody died even though
he dies us the fence will be finished in
a few days every day more than 1500
people try to cross the border from
Serbia into Hungary traveling along
what's called the Balkan route most come
from Central Asia Hungarian authorities
are struggling to cope the right-wing
nationalist government is spending 21
million euros on the fence to stem the
flow polish name it is mayor of the town
of Bashan Marsh near the Serbian border
it's directly on the route the migrants
take name it is in favor of the fence he
believes it might act as a deterrent
I think more than what you want this is
defense will be a real hurdle people who
try to break through it will be
committing a crime once it's up crossing
the border will no longer mean just
strolling over dos aguas de ma chère
beer honesty Ellen minta matachi Italia
hotel but even muhammad who has made his
way here from Afghanistan on crutches
says offense won't stop them what dear
what a Quahog our mission as we do all
well understand people who are running
for their lives who find a way to cross
the fence mission of asado in water
they'll climb over it or dig under it
one module my suggestion to Hungary is
make the fence a bit lower in some spots
inseong doors here but out of this will
you call it up and then even disabled
people like me will be able to cross it
does miss it one about one year ago it's
a bit of black humour but Mohammed knows
it's also a matter of survival
there aren't many people in Hungary
willing to help the migrants bollocks
Allah is an exception he's opposed to
the fence and believes Hungary is
sending the wrong signal to Europe about
the challenges that lie ahead isn't it
özil Kanak so lucky lucky man this fence
sends a message that the problem first
our government spread xenophobic
propaganda and now it's drumming up
support from people who are afraid of
migrants but in reality the government
can't cope with the migrants and isn't
fulfilling its obligation to the EU
right before these migrants cross into
the EU they find themselves stranded on
the Serbian side in the town of so
potica an abandoned brick factory has
become a gathering point for people who
have been on the road for months they're
hungry thirsty and at the end of their
strength posture Tibor Varga is trying
to help wherever he can this young man
needs a doctor
almost a hundred thousand migrants have
already arrived here this year their
goal is to reach Western Europe pastor
Varga does what he can but it's drop in
the bucket
and once the fence goes up things will
grow even more difficult here metre ten
o'clock or a mcore Naga - it's like a
dam like a mag Bolan what happens when
there's too much water it finds a way
over the dam and breaks through it if
there's no other way that's what will
happen with the flow of refugees they'll
break through the dam at its weakest
point Europe isn't taking this seriously
enough they need to step in any Latin
point is a not y como has a dish fences
are a less than ideal solution to the
problem once the fence here is complete
the migrants will just head for nearby
Romania to make the crossing into
Hungary then they'll be in the Schengen
area with open borders to Western Europe
for the migrants no risk is too great to
escape war and poverty at home